what is it that took you from a four to
an eight if nothing's changed what is it
that takes loving myself and and looking
in the mirror and not being disgusted at
what I see I understand that yeah so but
that doesn't you're you're not
necessarily being objective about how
other people view you right because
isn't that what a rating really is like
what you think the vast majority like
like if I rated myself one to ten I give
myself a five I think I'm normal looking
and I just think it's based my results I
think if I was in eight nine or ten I
would have had modeling contracts
because people in the top 20 of beauty
they get they get modeling contracts